(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula, nós vamos falar sobre a importância
do edital do leilão.
O edital do leilão, ele é a regra
específica daquele leilão.
Sem edital, nem existe aquele leilão específico.
É o edital que vai definir todos os
passos e todas as regras que vão ser
utilizadas no leilão de determinado bem.
Então, o edital, ele define a hora do
início e o fim da primeira e da
segunda praça, o valor do bem em primeira
praça e o valor de desconto que vai
ser oferecido o bem em segunda praça.
Vai apresentar a qualificação das partes envolvidas naquele
leilão.
Quem é o credor?
Quem é o devedor?
Quando apresenta a qualificação, apresenta a qualificação completa.
Nome completo, identidade, CPF, o endereço onde aquela
pessoa pode ser encontrada, se é casado ou
se não é casado, isso das duas partes.
Então, no edital, você consegue saber exatamente aquelas
partes que estão envolvidas ali e até usar
esses dados que o próprio edital te fornece
para tentar encontrar mais algum dado daquele devedor,
por exemplo.
Com o CPF do devedor, a gente vai
ter uma aula específica sobre um programa que
eu utilizo para coletar dados das pessoas e
com o CPF você consegue saber basicamente todos
os dados daquela pessoa.
Você consegue, através desse programa, encontrar os telefones
daquela pessoa, todos os endereços que ela já
morou.
O programa até te dá uma noção da
renda que aquela pessoa tem mensalmente.
No edital também vai estar a descrição de
quem é o leiloeiro, o nome do leiloeiro,
a matrícula do leiloeiro na junta comercial, qual
é o site que o leiloeiro usa para
fazer aquele leilão.
Tudo isso vai estar bem especificado no edital.
O edital também informa quem determinou aquele leilão,
se é um leilão judicial ou se é
um leilão extrajudicial.
Isso é muito importante para a gente saber
qual é a origem daquele leilão.
Se aquele leilão for um leilão extrajudicial, provavelmente
ele vai ser de uma dívida decorrente de
um contrato de alienação fiduciária.
Se aquele leilão for um leilão judicial, ele
vai ser decorrente de um processo judicial em
que alguém foi condenado judicialmente a pagar uma
quantia para outra pessoa.
Então é importante que a gente saiba isso,
até porque se for um leilão judicial, ele
tem regras específicas dos leilões judiciais, que a
gente vai estudar de forma pormenorizada no módulo
3.
Se ele for um leilão extrajudicial, ele também
tem regras específicas desse tipo de leilão, que
a gente vai estudar de forma pormenorizada no
módulo 2.
O edital também tem que, obrigatoriamente, mencionar os
gravames que recaiam sobre aquele imóvel.
E o que isso significa?
Se o imóvel foi dado em hipoteca, se
o imóvel foi dado em alienação fiduciária, se
o imóvel tem várias penhoras que recaiam sobre
ele para garantir diversas dívidas, tudo isso tem
que ficar bem consignado no edital do leilão.
Por quê?
Porque é o edital que vai dar publicidade
para aquele leilão.
Então o edital não pode omitir informações.
Sob pena de, depois de ser descoberta alguma
informação que estava omissa no edital, aquela informação
não vai poder ser repassada ao arrematante, porque
o arrematante não pode ser responsabilizado por aquilo
que o edital não disponibilizou de informação, porque
o edital é realmente a regra daquele leilão.
O edital, então, ainda tem que informar recursos
e processos pendentes sobre aquele imóvel.
Então o edital deve informar tudo o que
acontece ao redor daquele imóvel.
Se tem algum processo que envolve discussão com
aquele imóvel, o edital deve informar o número
do processo, sobre o que se trata o
processo, quem é o credor daquele processo.
Todas essas informações devem constar no edital.
O edital ainda vai falar se existe a
possibilidade de sobrar dívidas do imóvel para o
arrematante.
Quais são as dívidas do imóvel?
Condomínio e IPTU.
Então no leilão ex-predicial, o edital é
bem claro se vai sobrar ou se não
vai sobrar dívidas de condomínio e IPTU para
o arrematante, de quem vai ser a responsabilidade
pelas dívidas de condomínio e IPTU, até mesmo
anteriores à data do leilão.
No leilão judicial, a gente vai estudar um
pouco mais na frente, a regra é que
as dívidas de condomínio e IPTU serão subrogadas
no valor da arrematação.
O que significa falar que uma dívida vai
ser subrogada no valor da arrematação?
Significa falar que essas dívidas serão pagas com
o valor da arrematação, não serão de responsabilidade
do arrematante.
Mas apesar dessa ser a regra geral, de
além falar isso, a gente vai estudar especificamente
no módulo sobre leilão judicial que você deve
ficar bem atento ao que diz o edital
sobre as dívidas do imóvel e também ao
chamado concurso de credores, que são as outras
penhoras que possam recair sobre aquele mesmo imóvel.
Guarde essa informação que mais na frente a
gente vai falar de forma completamente detalhada sobre
esses dois pontos.
O edital também vai falar sobre o percentual
de comissão do leiloeiro.
Eu falei aqui anteriormente no curso que a
regra é que a comissão do leiloeiro tem
um percentual de 5% sobre o valor
da arrematação, mas pode ser que em algum
caso específico essa comissão do leiloeiro esteja com
um parâmetro um pouco diferente, com um percentual
diferente.
É bem comum, principalmente em leilões judiciais, que
o valor da comissão fique um pouco abaixo
desses 5%.
Por quê?
Pode ser que em algum caso específico de
um imóvel de elevado valor, o juiz entenda
que a remuneração que o leiloeiro faz jus
para aquele leilão, se for de 5%, vai
ficar muito elevada.
Então, pode ser que o juiz determine uma
comissão um pouco menor.
Geralmente, quando ocorre essa redução, cai de 5
% para 3%.
Então, se houver alguma diferença, isso tudo vai
estar consignado no edital.
Basta que você leia o edital, que você
vai saber lá qual é o percentual de
comissão do leiloeiro que vai incidir sobre aquele
leilão especificamente.
O edital ainda vai informar o valor da
dívida que levou o imóvel a leilão.
Então, é bem comum que nos editais a
gente encontre lá uma informação de dívida exequenda.
Essa dívida exequenda nada mais é do que
a dívida que originou aquele leilão em si.
O edital também coloca as formas de pagamento.
Se naquele leilão especificamente vai ser possível utilizar
um parcelamento, um financiamento e quais são as
condições, ou seja, qual é o máximo de
parcelamento que você pode usar naquele imóvel, quais
são as condições de correção monetária, eventual juros
que incida sobre aquele parcelamento, isso tudo também
você pode verificar no edital.
E o edital traz, por último, a informação
se o imóvel está ocupado ou se ele
está desocupado.
E aqui eu queria um momento de atenção
de vocês.
Por quê?
Por mais que o edital possa falar que
o imóvel está ocupado, você deve verificar se,
na prática, aquele imóvel realmente está ocupado.
Uma situação muito comum é que o ocupante
do imóvel, no momento que ele tem a
plena ciência de que seu imóvel está indo
a leilão, que ele não tem mais como
recorrer daquele leilão, é natural que ele desocupe
de forma voluntária o imóvel.
E aí, entre o prazo de elaboração do
edital e até a data efetiva da realização
do leilão, vai ocorrer um prazo.
Alguns meses podem passar durante esse período.
E pode ser que, nesses meses, a condição
de ocupação do imóvel já tenha realmente mudado
exatamente por isso.
Então pode ser que o edital seja elaborado
dois meses antes da data do leilão e,
naquele mês, realmente o imóvel estava ocupado.
Mas, na data da realização do leilão, existe
grande chance de aquele imóvel já estar desocupado.
Por isso que é muito importante que você
faça essa verificação na prática.
Vamos ter uma aula aqui no módulo 1
ainda sobre como verificar dados do imóvel, dados
do ocupante.
Recorra à maneira dessas aulas para você saber
se realmente o imóvel está ocupado ou não.
Apesar da ocupação não ser um problema no
leilão, 80% dos imóveis que vão ao
leilão estão ocupados.
E tudo bem se estiver ocupado, desde que
você verifique que o procedimento que deveria levar
o imóvel ao leilão está completamente correto.
Se estiver correto, você não deve temer a
desocupação.
Agora, é óbvio que pegar um imóvel desocupado
é muito mais tranquilo, porque aquele imóvel já
vai estar disponível quase que de imediato para
você.
Então, quando você faz essa verificação, pode ser
que muita gente que queira participar daquele leilão
não faça.
E aí você tenha uma informação que aquelas
pessoas não terão.
Porque quando o próprio leiloeiro coloca lá que
o imóvel está desocupado, por si só, aquele
leilão já vai atrair maior concorrência, porque vai
ser uma posse quase que de imediato.
Então, se você tiver essa informação, se o
leiloeiro não passar essa informação de forma pública,
porque realmente no momento de elaboração do edital
o imóvel estava ocupado, você sai na frente
das outras pessoas que estão analisando aquele leilão.
Então, esses são todos os requisitos que um
edital do leilão vai estipular.
É muito importante que você faça uma leitura
muito atenta sobre o edital do leilão.
Leia uma vez, duas vezes, três vezes.
O que eu recomendo, inclusive, é que você
comece a ler editais do leilão a partir
desse momento.
Comece a se familiarizar com os termos que
são usados.
Por mais que você possa encontrar lá algum
termo que você ainda desconhece, mas que durante
o curso a gente vai passar por esse
termo.
Comece a ler esses editais, comece a analisar
os descontos que os imóveis são oferecidos, como
é que o edital vai colocar a forma
de pagamento, se na maioria dos imóveis está
sendo oferecido uma oportunidade de parcelamento, de financiamento.
Alguns editais colocam desconto para pagamento à vista.
Comece a analisar todos esses detalhes.
E antes de participar de um leilão, efetivamente,
leia com muita atenção o edital do leilão.
Leia uma vez, duas vezes, quantas vezes foram
necessárias para que você se sinta seguro para
participar daquele leilão.
Se for possível, nos seus primeiros leilões, grife
as partes mais importantes do edital.
Isso com certeza vai te trazer maior segurança.
Não seja negligente com a leitura do edital
do leilão, porque realmente o edital é a
regra específica do leilão de determinado imóvel.